mauvais souvenir c'est qu'on n'était pas
sûr de tourner moi je voulais absolument
tourner l'été sachant qu'on a lu très
peu de financement on n'était pas sur le
tour n'est donc ça c'est un truc qui m'a
frustré pendant un petit moment et après
une fois qu'on a tourné c'était quel est
mon souvenir clairement pendant six
semaines que des bons souvenirs
vraiment ça a été une belle aventure
bien évidemment avec de temps en temps
des moments un peu de doute mais mais à
l'arrivée
voilà on était assez content d'avoir pu
faire ce film
bonjour mademoiselle contrôle de police
moi j'ai le pire c'est quand on a dû
faire les scènes de course poursuite on
a beaucoup couru et les petits courts
très très vite
du coup on était vraiment bien ridicule
- ou pire souvenir c'était la course
poursuite parce que fallait il va faire
beaucoup de fois et c'était assez long
c'était sur plusieurs endroits à la fois
et il faisait chaud c'était un peu
compliqué mais ça ça va mais beaucoup de
choses fortes à un pis c'est marrant il
ya plein de scènes qui conte et qui ont
été créés pour le film qu'on continue à
vivre après ta truc je pense notamment
aux petits campements des gamins avec
leurs piscines leur truc la scène elle
dure pas longtemps ils ont passé toute
l'après-midi la sphère des débats
moussan et des trucs non la surprise
c'était surtout les comédiens et les
comédiens parce qu'on a les trois
principaux que sur les comédiens
professionnels et tous les autres qu'on
a cassé c'est des gens qui habitent le
quartier donc c'est des gens qui avaient
pas spécialement d'expérience dans le
cinéma ou en tant qu'acteur et sur sa
wii on était bluffé de cerveau de voir à
quel point il était bon ils étaient
juste c'était incroyable vraiment en
fait c'est assez drôle parce que de base
le réalisateur il était dans mon lit il
est venu me chercher il m'a dit viens
avec moi je savais pas où j'allais il
m'a dit tiens tu vas faire une audition
j'ai eu la chance d'être prêt et c'est
que quelques mois plus tard sur le
tournage que je me suis vraiment rendu
compte de ce que je faisais moi y avait
beaucoup de vent et on pouvais pas m
depuis le donc j'avais très très froid
moi c'est surtout quand je me fais tirer
au flashball thème on a fait deux prises
j'avais mal à la tête j'ai dû me reposer
pendant assez longtemps c'est que des
bons moments après le reste que du fait
du plaisir